oh it's shay
are you gonna answer it no
i mean i want to but i'm not
i've been too available lately oh so
you're doing the rules now
you're gonna tell them you can't go out
tomorrow night because you're washing
your hair stop it
just pulling back a little
right
miranda is so overwhelmed
by how attracted she is to che and how
off-kilter that shay has thrown her that
she becomes charlotte and starts doing
the rules that's right
right like miranda is charlotte season
two
what is it that we're supposed to learn
what is miranda representing in this
journey of discovery
i mean you know the age that these
characters are you know is like you know
like i'm 55 i'm going to be 56 this year
and that's thank you and that's
miranda's age and it's like you reach a
moment you know you can when you put a
negative spin on it you can call it like
a mid-life crisis right but out of
crises come really productive things and
it's like you're you're not young
anymore but you're not old either and
you still have time to like make sure
that your life is the way you want it to
be and if you're
deeply unhappy in your career choices
and you're you're really deeply unhappy
in your marriage you should look at it
and demand more right and if you're also
having a giant change in your life are
you not acting
giddy and youthful and
off-kilter i mean that's what it seems
like miranda's going through right i
mean miranda is very smart and she's
very tenacious and very strong but she's
always been kind of a volenda china shop
kind of rushing ahead and then maybe
having to to go back and like sweep up
the china afterwards do you know i mean
it's it's interesting that people
i don't know i i think some people are
not loving seeing
um these characters maybe off-kilter but
i love that you know
love it
it makes me
so appreciative
that
time has passed and people have changed
i am so
not who i was
five years ago let alone 10 years ago
and we whatever age you are you haven't
figured out everything out if you've if
you think you've figured everything out
you're kidding yourself
and now hbo presents the new show
um the gilded age which i saw the first
episode i'm so excited will you tell us
about this show yes so um
i was a huge downton abbey fan so when
the chance to be in the julian fellows
american show came i of course was so
excited but you know christine and i
have known each other speaking of mike
nichols for a very long time because i
guess next year it will be 40 years ago
mike nichols directed us in a play in
which she played my mother and i
worshiped her then and i worship her now
and so we get to play this funny odd
couple this this pair of sisters who
live together um one is single one is
widowed and uh they're they're like an
odd couple they're like an old married
couple and she has all the power and the
gravitas and i'm the you know the one
kind of you know always always in motion
uh you know kind of hard on my sleeve
trying to fix everything and it's very
upstairs downstairs and i keep also
hoping that because the roaring 20s came
out of a pandemic that maybe we might
have the roaring 20s all over again so
i'm kind of hoping for that
revival
but the ultimate revival in our world is
and just like that and episode 9 comes
out tomorrow there are 10 episodes 10
episodes so we're gearing towards the
end i don't want it to end
[Music]
you